let's get to five headlines
[Music]
okay um well here we go again protests
in la last night more protests this one
started with blm
los angeles sending out this tweet here
it says los angeles county sheriff's
killed a black man dejean
on 109th and bud long and left his body
face down in the dirt
we need all hands on deck please get
here asap
notice how there's no information about
the circumstances of the shooting
just that somebody was shot that's
because it doesn't matter they don't
care
if police kill a black man for any
reason literally
any reason now they will riot
that's the way this is going and so it
doesn't matter
uh what the circumstances are but as far
as they go
um just just uh just you know for the
record
as far as we know them anyway right now
the suspect got into a fight with cops
punched the cops had a gun at one point
produced the handgun
and uh and then was shot still plenty of
unknown details here
but but based on what we know there's of
course no reason to be protesting
if there is a reason then we don't have
that information yet
armed man physically assaults cops okay
that's the headline so far
um and if if that's what happened then
guess whose fault it is when the armed
man assaulting the cops
gets hurt or killed oh you know by the
way the cop who pulled the trigger
appears to be hispanic
on top of it although we're told white
hispanic
you know so we're doing that trick again
there's a he's hispanic but he's white
hispanic so we can still make this about
white suprema
white supremacy once again though you
see how all agency and willpower is
removed from the suspects in these
police shootings
it's the way it always goes you know
they assault cops draw weapons etc
and we act like they play no role at all
in their own death
like they couldn't have been expected to
not
do that but the thing is you know this
is not a coincidence that almost
everyone in america
white black any other race who doesn't
assault cops
and use weapons on them manages to not
get shot by
the police crazy coincidence right i
don't think it is
like there's a there's a real connection
here
i succeed in not assaulting cops every
day of my
life i it's it's you know i i just did
it again yes
yesterday i went through a whole day
didn't assault any police officers
and i also was not shot by any police
officers i really think there might be
a connection i got pulled over recently
and um through the whole interaction i
actually did not at any point
punch the police officer i did get a
ticket
but the thing is if if i had decided to
punch the police officer
there are basically two you know
what would have been a ticket now it's
going to be different i'll still get the
ticket
but if i'm still alive but
when i start that assault of the police
officer there's really only two
directions i can go
one is me to prison um dealing with a
much worse charge or or infraction than
what it would have been otherwise
or dead you know or in the hospital
paralyzed i mean
those are really the only it's like once
you start doing that
there's there's no good result for you
at all
i mean there might be good results for
the hacks and race-baiters and
charlatans out there
who want to use your death or your
maiming your injury
uh to advance their own narrative and to
sow you know more uh division and
everything
so for them sure but for you no
this is like a really basic message that
somehow gets lost
we forget to mention it
okay let's go um number two here's
another thing
you wouldn't expect but big surprise
here people are upset about something
that trump said
uh they are i know really surprising
uh so let's take a let's listen to this
he was on he was in on
laura ingram last night and uh then he
you know he was talking and everything
that he said was horribly offensive
this part right here was super offensive
and upsetting though listen to this
black lives matter is a marxist
organization
you remember pigs in a blanket fry them
like bacon that was the first time i
ever heard of black lives matter
i said that's a terrible name it's so
discriminatory it's bad for black people
it's bad for everybody
and all of a sudden it becomes like sort
of although now if you look it's going
way down because people are tired of
this stuff what's going on
the black lives matter if you look at
what's going on with the bats and the
a lot of thugs running through dc last
night oh it's terrible what's going on
my god how dare you trump how dare you
say these things
that are incontrovertibly and obviously
correct yes black lives matter is a
marxist organization
their founders have said so publicly why
are we still pretending that this is
some sort of offensive they've said it
listen to them they're the ones
we didn't say it it's not our fault i'd
prefer
black lives matter was not in a marxist
organization but it is
and that's what their own founders have
said so there you go
um now now that we've checked in with
trump let's see what uh
biden is up to covert has taken this
year
just since the outbreak has taken more
than
100 years look here's the lives
it's just it's when you think about it
more lives this year than any other year
for the past hundred years
okay i have a transcript here um if you
didn't follow that
the transcript is coveted has taken this
year just since the outbreak it's taken
more than a hundred years
look here's the lives it's just it's
just think about it more lives this year
than any other year for the past 100
years
i'm not trying to be funny i really have
no idea what he's even trying to say
there i can't decipher it
this isn't one of those times where
somebody stumbles or has a gaff
and you kind of know what they were
trying to say but you pretend that you
don't just just to try to just do a you
know
just to dig the um dig the knife in
deeper i
but no this is not that i really don't
even know what he was going for it's
taken more lives than at any other point
in the last 100 years is that what he's
trying to say covet 19 is a new thing it
hasn't been around so
i don't know what that means and just so
you know what you saw there
you know um because it's tempting when
you see these kinds of things with biden
to say well look he had a brain fart
you know he stumbled over his words
everybody does it um yeah everyone does
i mean i've had many brain farts in my
day
uh i have a particularly flatulent brain
in that way
and i stumble over my words all the time
but
something like that that's not normal
that is just not normal to complete
in the middle of a sentence you
completely
lose everything you are going to say
and it's especially not normal when it
happens all the time like it does with
joe biden
uh number four jk rowling still
suffering the consequences of publicly
acknowledging that biology exists has
now
given back her robert f kennedy ripple
of hope human rights award
which is good because now they have an
extra one lying around so now i can
finally
win it you know um but she gave it back
after the president of the organization
kerry kedney came out
and attacked rowling for believing that
men can't get pregnant very you know
obviously very offensive
thing to believe and uh so i'm reading
now from forbes it says carrie kennedy
published a statement this month to the
rfk human rights website
displaying multiple statements made by
rowling in recent months
and saying um
on and and uh and okay this is what she
said no i'm losing track of what i said
no i'm pulling a button
uh so this is this is carrie kennedy she
says i have spoken with jk rowling to
express my profound disappointment
that she has chosen to use her
remarkable gifts to create a narrative
that diminishes the identity of trans
and non-binary people
undermining the validity and integrity
of the entire transgender community
trans rights are human rights j.k
rowling's attacks upon the transgender
community are inconsistent with the
fundamental beliefs and values of rfk
human rights
and represent a repudiation of my
father's vision
um okay
can i just say if someone's opinion
somehow undermines the validity and
integrity
of your very existence then you might
have issues that go way beyond
that opinion i in my life have
never felt that the validity of my
existence was undermined by anyone's
words or thoughts
and i've been insulted many times i
assure you
i i have many very horrible things have
been said to me
um i would wager in fact that i have
heard more horrible things said to me
and about my family than the average
transgender person has heard in their
life
i i think i can feel pretty confident in
that
um but in in any case and sometimes it
takes me off it's annoying
i don't like it i've never felt that the
validity of my existence was undermined
i don't even know what that means
i exist i'm sure of that
i don't need the i don't need my
validity or the integrity of my
existence to be affirmed by anyone
so this constant need for affirmation
this panic
um that you see you know uh from lgbt
activist folks the
the way they panic if anywhere set if
anywhere
if anyone anywhere says anything that
lgbt activists don't like
um the fact that they always need
everyone all the time to validate them
and will try to destroy anyone who fails
to provide that validation
that might speak to some deeper things
going on
i don't know just a thought you know if
you feel like you need your existence
your very existence and what was it she
said the integrity
the integrity of the entire community
if you feel like you need your existence
to be validated and the integrity of
your
community validated whatever that means
then again i would say maybe there's
some deeper things going on
okay five finally for our most important
story of the day residents of an alabama
town are being terrorized
by a goat who eats
their mail this harrowing footage was
uploaded to facebook
you take a look at it here there's the
goat
there he is that bastard look at him
that's a federal crime by the way
this is not a joke there could have been
a coupon for 10 off a new mattress in
there
now that's gone it's that that's he's
stealing money that's money out the
window
let me tell you there's a reason that
goats have always been considered
satanic
they eat your mail they have weird
looking eyes
they they do other
things i mean you may be wondering why i
take the goat issue so seriously
and you may wonder why i'm still talking
about it right now
and you may be thinking matt the goat
joke is over move on
well i'll tell you why because my wife
has been recruiting my children my
children my own flesh and blood
has been recruiting them and together
they have been waging a pressure
campaign against me for months now to
get me to consent to buying a goat
this is a serious thing now in my family
they want a goat i don't know why
the other day my daughter came into the
living room started talking about the
goat
oh daddy can we get a go i see my wife
behind the door like feeding her lines
okay it's a conspiracy
but i'm not gonna have this mailbox
tampering scumbag anywhere near my home
that's all i'm saying
so goats are canceled that was a
pre-cancellation before we get to the
main cancellation of the day
hey you uh yeah you you're right you
right there
hit the subscribe button right now do it
do it right now
i thank you for your compliance it's
somewhat appreciated